so Andrew Tate says you're not stupid
and he's talking to one of the victims
you're not stupid and you can probably
guess how I make so much money I have to
hide what I'm really doing and the
victim says the webcam and he says I've
been doing this for a long time with a
team of girls working on video chat the
company was fake but this is how I
laundered my dirty money
some of the girls who worked for me I
use them to do other things
to move money or illegal things
documents and I will never do that with
you if you aren't aware
teach them prison in Romania some people
say he's innocent other people say he's
guilty and you guys remember us we said
wait till the evidence comes out we'll
find out well a lot of evidence has been
coming out that prosecutor's office in
Romania has been leaking a lot and uh
how can you be a prosecutor's office and
leaking that much let's always do it the
real purpose yeah yeah they leak what
they want to the Press you have to
understand it's a whole game
we didn't get a case for them it's not
just winning a case there's a lot of ego
involved these people want to win these
big cases when the FBI says it's got a
what 96 98 conviction rate the reason
why is because they like that [ __ ] on
their resume they take on cases they
know they're gonna win and they only put
forth the case when they know they're
going to win yeah and so this thing
right here have you seen what they
leaked no I haven't seen one thing
listen they didn't prosecute Andrew take
Andrew take prosecutor Angel Tate my
homie was self snitching oh that bad
what's the take so basically watch the
tape it's trafficking we have three
things a force
fraud or coercion
Sports obviously that's like being in
Chains and you know not being allowed to
leave
fraud being kept there under false
pretenses if there's an element of fraud
in the way that you are enticing
somebody or keeping somebody in a
particular position to work for you and
if it's in the sex business that's sex
trafficking or coercion let's kind of
look at one of his very first videos
that he did these are his words not my
words when you say webcam company people
assume oh it's just a sex faster but
reality it's a shitload of people
management the Hedgehog haggery of the
webcam business is is the largest and
most important thing you're effectively
taking girls teaching them how to make
unlimited money from home and then
making sure they give all to you your
goal is to inspire a girl to make money
so the way you're going to do that is
you have to have some element of
influence and you're going to have that
element of influence through her
respecting you looking up to you and her
believing she needs you and this is
extremely important because at the
beginning she will need you but then she
won't need you but you have to keep that
fallacy keep that dream alive fallacy
that's his word and what does fallacy
fraud that's a pimp
that's that's exactly
what a pimp does I need some Street pins
I've known for a long time Straight
Street pimping is completely in fact now
it's not completely different again the
psychological aspect is the same she
can't do this without you to ensure that
she doesn't do it without the beginning
she can't but there'll become a point
she can
but you being here
it synergizes this teamwork energy we're
going to do this together yeah you go on
the camera don't worry I'll talk to the
guys I'm going to talk to them today
we're a team that did a happy positive
teamwork there's no negative energy in
this business you imagine you talking to
this hot blonde girl and you webcam with
her and you sending her messages and you
find out it's actually just a
bald-headed top G on the other side
that's
I'm sorry
the reason why I'm having this face is
because the amount I didn't realize
how much foot and mouth could contain oh
oh he's [ __ ] up oh oh they got all
the receipts on this guy and it gets
worse
I have to be positive
so by you typing for the girl you
maximize your money
another reason you share bank is because
they will pay you in Bitcoin and this is
amazing because the you've all seen the
thought audit [ __ ] that's going on
you've all seen the [ __ ] legalities
of banking trying to get money out of
these sites into your bank without
paying a shitload of tax is actually
very difficult see it's that that whole
avoiding taxes and it's not legal to do
that in the last six months chat right
have released a Bitcoin options they'll
pay you a Bitcoin tax is also another
important element of controlling your
woman you're not going to pay any money
tax because you're getting paid in
Bitcoin so you don't need to pay tax to
anybody tell your girl
that you're paying the tax because girls
are lazy girls are stupid and girls
don't understand how taxes work so the
girls working with you and you're like
oh okay yeah we've made this much money
but I'm gonna pay the tax to make sure
we don't get in trouble
she'll sit there go okay okay now that
allows you to do two things one is
another control element I work with him
my tax is not a problem if I do it alone
I have to deal with taxes taxes are
complicated and I'm just gonna pay her a
smaller percentage
so I used to pay my girls 13
so for every ten thousand dollars they
made I give them three and I keep seven
they thought they were on fifty percent
and I said that the disparity was
because of taxes so you're on fifty
percent we have to pay the tax first and
then it's 50 50. so really you're paying
30 you tell them you're paying 50.
difference is in the tax
that's where the disparity lies taxes if
you if they don't leave you they want to
get fresh or whatever print out some tax
forms I see this all the time has to
print out some random tax forms say
assign here and sign this what is it for
the tax you want to pay the tax or not
okay and they just signed away look at
the [ __ ] signing let's throw them
away they think something's happening
something real is happening nothing
nothing
so we started uh he's already admitted
to tax evasion and fraud I mean it's not
a mission he's
this is a course he's running he's
teaching people that's what he's
teaching he doesn't mean he's doing that
now now now I'm just playing devils
it's a very hard job I'm just I'm not
saying um
[Laughter]
he said that's what he was doing with
this girls that's what he said he was
doing yeah
the women saying he did this to us
oh
what you think they're gonna look at the
bank records and see that the money oh
he was paying them 50 50. what you think
let's be honest if someone admits to
what they're doing just believe them but
to his defense
I got nothing
snitching so what you're telling me is
that they got him on frauding the girls
and the frauding the government is that
what you're saying I just want you guys
to understand like just here we're not
even going to the human track just right
there
this man was stealing from the people
that were working for him
it's right there
he didn't even care he said I'm getting
rich [ __ ] [ __ ] you he didn't care he
was stealing from
if that's your job how would you feel
about that would you not want this
person to charge for that crime
listen if my employer even stole one
dollar an hour from me I'd be pissed
thousands every single month something
real is happening nothing happens
you could not do a business relationship
with a female I'll tell you why
women have sex with somebody
from somebody else and that other person
she's talking is going to have the
control over her mind as opposed to you
and if he controls her mind and you
don't control her mind once she starts
to pick it up a bit after a few weeks a
few months whatever and realize it's how
to make money on her own or she could
run off and pay her boyfriend or them to
her to go traveling in Southeast Asia
and she's going to work how she knows or
she's going to go to her boyfriend and
say look [ __ ] it you type for me oh yeah
you're always working I have to do some
traveling and you can't come I want to
bring you with me traveling is a great
one because the thing about this
business is mobile if you can find a
good Airbnb with good internet you can
run it somewhere else so it's a good
little caveat to throw in uh you're
always working why don't you work for me
so we spend more time together or if
you're doing once a lot of webcam
business oh I don't want to do that it's
okay I know you don't want to do that
but listen come let's have a meeting
let's just talk about it we don't want
to do it don't do it fine let me explain
it to you properly in fact I'll bring
one of the girls who works for me
is the one who does the selling you
don't do the selling the girl has to
hear from a girl and this is why you
bought me just be trained that's why
it's so important to have a good first
girl remember Glenn Maxwell that was the
girl that recruited for Jeffrey Epstein
almost identical to what he's talking
about here
you guys remember so this is why this is
important this push right here it
doesn't prove anything but it is one of
the little piece of evidence that they
add in for the whole trafficking charge
basically he he has a woman okay who
used to be former police officer in
Romania she's the one who does the
recruiting the managing of the women why
because women are much more likely to be
roped into these kinds of things if
they're hearing it from another woman so
when he sets up his organization right
because they're accusing him of running
a criminal organization he has the woman
who he calls his moment right to recruit
The Other Women okay
now
there's some transcripts because they
did some wire tabs they seems their
phones he sees all their technology so
there's some conversations that they're
using now I want you to also know the
context of the country's in Andrew Chang
is a foreigner living in Romania as a
rich person trying to get trying to
[ __ ] steal from the government and
he's also spoken about the reason why he
left the UK to go to Romania is because
you know I mean laws are a little bit
lacks they're not like it's not as real
oppressive so this is how he talks about
Romania and going to jail there okay
this is this is pulled from his PC and
then there was a leaked to the press
okay so this is something that they got
partner radio
corruption free Ze we put in jail I'm
gonna walk in there with a pile of money
like this
this sells mine I'm ready put me in
there I'm gonna walk paper Courtney get
me out of jail so Laurel says you're
guilty I said get me out of jail I'll go
see a lawyer to talk about the law I've
committed multiple felonies
to make this all go away also in your
real G is that you're here you're there
you're everywhere you gotta go to Poland
you gotta go to Warsaw [ __ ] Dubai
Miami anyone who wants to take
confidential notes I'm all over the
place so end up with all these chicks
just stuck in our house sitting there
bored completely in love with me and of
course they don't go out they're not
allowed out you stay in the house you
don't go nowhere you know no restaurants
no clubs nothing but here's even the
kicker looking at private videos of the
part of the police file uh from the con
I see it the following passages from the
context of this content there is no
doubt a deep lack of respect for the
legal norms and a total indifference to
the social protected values that the
defendant gives proof of also the
attitude of disregard towards women in
general which he perceives only as a
mean of getting his content and release
in other words making money the judge
cannot agree with the support of the
defense in the sense that the video
contents presents only one character and
cannot be taken into account since the
defendant exhibits the same attitude in
their relations with the injured persons
and is evident from the content of the
conversations that are in these criminal
prosecution basically the judge like now
the way you act in real life is how you
talk about these videos so I'm not going
to not use them as evidence I cannot use
them as evidence because they match
let's get to the transcripts
because people are saying wait you got
more
when I say listen and just a pro tip if
you're a criminal watching do not use
WhatsApp okay do not use WhatsApp to do
any of your criminal activity they keep
a record the r records are on locks as
easy but traceable bro I'm gonna tell
you this don't use your phone
do not use your phone
I'm talking about I've have
friends that were in instances where
they crossed the borders and they have
certain
um
software that could tap in your phone
and get the deleted items you can always
go get the deleted items so that's the
reason why they have burner phones don't
use your phone
actually you have to use a phone crack
it and keep on going you know those flip
phones that's pretty much what you'd
have to use all right so yeah I digress
so these are these are leak transcripts
from the stenographer either in the
court case or leaked from the
prosecutor's office the reason why
they're doing this is they like the
media attention being involved in this
the prosecutor May probably some ego
involved and he wants to let everybody
know I'm going to be the person who
takes down tape and listen it only
matters if he's got evidence to back it
up and he's done some digging and it
seems that during their eight months of
searching and their raids on the
compound they found quite a lot oh my
God
okay so this is how Andrew Tate
apparently manipulates one of the
victims of the flight of Romania by
promising marriage
then discusses said victim has a
commodity to be used for making money
Andrew Tate says you have to understand
what the once your mind you'll might be
mine forever a woman never leaves her
man and I'll be the last man in your
life what do we do if we fall in love
and I kidnap you to bring you to
Bucharest another grower plus I don't
think it's kidnapping if I want to come
first I have to see in your eyes that
you will never be able to live without
me and then I can trust you to show you
everything bring a ring when you come
this is what the girl said he says can
you be loving enough to be a wife to
always be on my side wherever I go to
talk to zero men besides me and you have
to move to Romania with me to keep an
eye on you your mind don't ever forget
that and she says but can I trust you he
says yes you can
will mean Romania and I want to know
your comedian and serious about marriage
yes I'm serious and when she gets there
he's like well we're not getting married
I want to turn you into a cam girl okay
so they're basically establishing that
the way that he's getting these people
involved in the whole business is to
fraud and if you remember what the guy
said earlier in regards to some of the
criteria that need to be met okay
one of them is fraud and that's what
they're trying to establish with these
conversations when they're released so
even though this conversation doesn't
seem bad to you you have to understand
by the letter of the law and how they
Define human trafficking this is one of
those elements that they might
incorporate in order to make that charge
stick basically he wants to tell these
people hey I'm running a can of business
come down he's like I want to marry you
you're going to fall in love with me
you're gonna fall in love with me he
gets them all the way down to Romania
inside of his compound then he Springs
it on him with who his mother so Andrew
Tate says you're not stupid and you and
he's talking to one of the victims
you're not stupid and you can probably
guess how I make so much money I have to
hide what I'm really doing and the
victim says the webcam and he says I've
been doing this for a long time with a
team of girls working on video chat the
company was fake but this is how I
laundered my dirty money
some of the girls who worked for me I
use them to do other things
to move money or illegal things
documents and I will never do that with
you basically telling the girl you're
different from the others I make them do
the really illegal stuff again they have
it right here in the wiretaps okay the
hymn admitting to this stuff this is
going to be used in court and you're
gonna have a hard time explaining this
one away what is this money laundering
that you were doing you can't go to the
court be like hey what happened was let
me scratch your head yeah okay so now
here comes the next part this is the I
think the biggest one Tate's Angels
meaning the bottom of the two women
these are the women who work for him the
Glenn Maxwell's if you don't make money
we're gonna have a problem punch
yourself in the mouth until I arrive
because then I'll give you another 10
you incurable slacker
and the other girl says I'll break you
when I get there and the victim says
what did I do
and the bottom is you have one hour and
10 minutes to disappear and the victims
but what did I do you're down 20 four
days since you posted and she says if
Andrew looks to see you if you posted
tick tocks you won't even have time to
pack you're flying off the balcony
straight away
so what does this conversation really
mean this is where this is important it
might not mean much to y'all because
you're like well when they're taking
this in conjunction with everything else
the fraud element involved the coercion
element the aspect of like lying about
what they're really going to be doing
there the fact that this girl who works
for Tate is saying he's going to be
punching the girl 10 times when she gets
there there's these threats of violence
the one saying like age gets home you're
gonna be flying off the balcony is that
literally probably not but there is some
element there of threats of potential
violence what if you don't do what's
needed when you take that to court and
these are conversations that are
happening in private you understand
they're going to take this into strong
consideration when they're making their
case they're like how do you explain
this stuff
oh we're just joking We're Not Gonna
actually make her well then why is the
victim terrified
oh she's just lying and making you think
that's gonna really be a real defense in
court you know the thing is um there's
some people that are not going to
believe that of course there's going to
be a lot of guys gonna be like yeah this
ain't that bad it ain't that bad and you
know why because they actually talk like
that
they talk like that with their girls the
girls I'm saying guys but I'm talking
girls do the same [ __ ]
oh my God oh my God I swear imma punch
you in your mouth and people talk like
that on a regular basis I was
astonished at the fact the language that
some people use with their friends or
with their loved ones yeah but it's just
I'm just talking it's just this is just
that whenever you talk to them whenever
you check them so you know listen you
cannot talk to me any kind of way you
can't talk to me about you're gonna
punch me in my face you can't tell me
that you're gonna kick me in my throat
you can't do [ __ ] like that ah but you
know man I'm just it's just it's just
talk it ain't real these people are
gonna be super motivated to do this take
Lou from the UK to Romania because the
Justice in the UK said it was too
prejudicial and they were going to come
after a strong Romanians more lacks you
went to Romania after the fool wanted to
say anything and do anything and engage
in illegal activity listen you [ __ ]
around and you found out you gotta hold
that L nobody told you to self snitch
that's not [ __ ] around
that's not like people just getting on
camera and just calmly admitting to
criminal activity is so crazy to me
people say why would anybody do that why
would people do that and be a public
personality because some people got ego
because some people don't know how to
stay away from them [ __ ] cameras
because they hit too big look at same
bank for freed right dude ran FTX turned
out to be a big old fraudster after the
fraud was discovered you know what this
idiot was doing he was getting on live
television doing interviews
incriminating himself further and those
interviews that he did after being found
out are going to be used against him in
court why because some people can't stop
themselves from doing stupid [ __ ]
things and I'm sure if he had a lawyer
at the time when caught
like telling him what to do they would
say don't do any interviews but he
couldn't help himself why because his
ego I'm just really here to see where it
goes
I'm gonna see where it goes because like
Abba said
if that's what the leaking did I press
they got some bigger thing bangers bars
jail bars but they got something bigger
and what they're going to do to court is
going to be something else it's going to
be something crazier if that's what they
choose to lead to court anyways all that
to say I'll wait I'll stand by here
it's just there's a lot there's a lot of
Kanye complex that I call whenever you
go on a podcast and you say I'm gonna
say whatever the hell I want
and he's still they can't they can't
they can't un they can unwork with me
okay then he said some outline this [ __ ]
and it was like whoa let's drop your ass
and everybody started chopping and
nobody wants to work that's the same
kind of complex hey I can walk in this
country and do whatever the hell I want
I could pay this I could pay that I
could do this this top genius building
yeah yeah
and then this will happen and now he's
in a Romanian jail cell with 30 other
dudes in a toilet in the Middle where
everyone got to watch each other's [ __ ]
Hey listen but it don't look good Hey
listen they have transcripts once I seen
that video of him snitching I said it
don't matter what I think you know what
it looked like I know he didn't pay his
taxes one because he said he didn't pay
his taxes he didn't pay people and he
didn't pay people because he admits to
stealing their money that's not even if
they can prove that he was abusing
[ __ ] forget that if they can
just just yeah I understand that on the
basis of those two things
it's just like a tuna casserole it don't
look good